what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into Spyder getting um
this is actually the zero issue this is
kind of the one that's somewhat of a
premium in all honesty it really could
just be considered edge of spider-verse
but as a zero issues one of things to be
a month those guys who were new zero
issues were actually originally
pioneered by Valiant Comics back in the
early 1990s but DC co-opted them and
then started turning him into like
origin stories and things like that but
when it comes to zero issues they're
essentially just pre Lutz is really all
they are but at the end of the day um
this one the reason why I say it could
be considered like edge of spider it's a
Edyta spider gedan is because the edge
of spider getting stories were designed
to either reintroduce we're really just
designed to reintroduce you to existing
characters that's all we didn't really
cover it outside of like Spider Hulk I'm
sorry Spider Punk is because you know
when it came to like edge of
spider-verse that was like all these
different versions of spider-man edges
fighter Ganon is just like hey guys
rumor goes spider-man from spider-verse
well here they are again and that's
really all it was but this one is
particularly cool because what this does
is it brings the Playstations for us
playstation for spider-man into the fold
of Marvel Comics and we knew is only
ever a matter of time rightly at this
point like like for the most part Marvel
Comics um is just kind of copying what
the MCU does and then is also just like
grabbing things from stuff like like
video games and so on and so forth so
for the most part Marvel's not really
standalone too much anymore in terms of
the comics and they are to a degree um
but it's I guess it's really bringing
them closer in line but for the most
part just kind of doing what the MCU
does and so with this in mind what we
end up doing here is picking up with the
you know play say it like playstation
man like like play spider I don't know
what I don't know what to call him like
he needs a version he needs us a Spider
Man kind of nickname that's okay i'ma
leave it to you guys he needs a
spider-man nickname that's that ties him
into the PlayStation 4 you know so like
spite like game spider or something like
that I don't really know but anyway so
ps4 Spider Man is basically dealing with
a villain with with tarantula now
tarantula is an interesting I mean not
really interesting but using care do
that goes back a little ways in Marvel
Comics but he doesn't go like far back
far back and he doesn't usually go like
super far back but he is still a
relatively interesting character in
terms of the role that he plays and what
I mean here is is tarantula was
introduced was originally introduced
back in 1974 with amazing spider-man
number 134 as part of Jerry Conway's run
and the idea was that he was essentially
like a revolutionary in in South America
the idea was that as part of this
revolutionary group while they were okay
with using extreme tactics what this did
is it also it created kind of a rule of
like hey this is what we do but like we
don't take the life of innocent
if we don't need to and tarantula
actually killed security guard which in
turn got him exiled but the government
turned him into kind of like a fascist
Captain America but then when he killed
an innocent guy yet again the government
booted him out and then he took up
residence in New York and he fought
spider-man for a little while but he was
never like a major player right like he
was like spider-man's version of like
Batroc the leaper more or less like
Captain America um and it was okay I
mean it was cool for what it was but he
was never like a big name right like he
was never on par with like Doctor
Octopus or anybody along those lines but
in the ps4 universe he's actually more
akin to like iron spider in terms of
like the technology he has and how he
uses it but again it's not a great big
huge thing because of course spider-man
defeats him relatively easily by using a
spider bomb and that's when the superior
spider-man shows up now this is when
things start to get a little bit hairy
because at the time that we have
superior spider-man in the story we also
have superior octopus in the main Marvel
Universe like that's the that that is
Doctor Octopus after the events of
co-conspiracy basically the new Clone
Saga where he basically duplicates his
own body because remember doctor
octopus's original body died he put his
consciousness in Peter Parker's body and
took over Peter Parker's body during
superior spider-man and so when Peter
Parker got his body back the
consciousness of Doctor Octopus was put
inside a robot and so after the events
of clone conspiracy he cloned his own
body and then he came back as Doc Ock
and became superior octopus and that fed
in a secret Empire and so with this
whole thing happening like in reality at
least as far as at the time this story
is being told we're just to say in issue
number 0 we don't know how superior
spider-man's back or if we do I don't
know so on maybe maybe I miss something
I'm not entirely sure but it's basically
superior spider-man meeting ps4 LPS for
spider-man and it's awesome which by the
way can we all just admit that the
costume of Peter Parker and the
PlayStation 4 game is probably one of
the best versions of the spider-man
costume ever like the original
spider-man costume that I mean you'll
never get better than that because it's
classic but like in terms of all the
variations of the spider-man costumes
we've seen I would say if I had to put
in order I would say the original
spider-man costume superior spider-man
Miles Morales ps4 like I love this
version it's pretty cool the way it's
set up now one of the things about the
two of these Caird is meeting each other
is remember in the for those of you guys
you never play the PlayStation 4 version
of spider-man when it came to that
version of Doctor Octopus there's
history there more so than you would
expect in the sense that when it comes
to the ps4 spider-man this is a scenario
where when Doctor Octopus of the
PlayStation universe came into existence
he was a business partner alongside
Norman Osborn and the
idea was to kind of change the worldwide
it was like their own mini version of
the Future Foundation or like horizon
labs and what this did is it turned into
a scenario where Norman Osborn just
basically started focusing on money and
it's kind of left dr. octopus or I guess
Otto Octavius disheartened so we started
Octavius industries and the issue was
that because he was essentially kind of
funded by Norman Osborn that's really
how he was able to pull off all the
things that he was doing at the end of
the day where Peter Parker became kind
of like a protege and in an octave eeeh
stood Peter Parker under his wing the
result was that with octavius's projects
being a centered failures by Norman
Osborn Norman Osborn took everything
like literally took everything from-from
Octavius and that left him basically
bitter in disgruntled so an attorney
became a villain with the intention of
just like tearing down everything Norman
Osborn luck this brought him and
spider-man in a conflict and because of
the fact that Octavius had been using
toxins in order to use his Octopus
appendages it has simply drove him
insane and left him in like a really
screwed-up state and so that's that's
kind of where that comes from but when
Peter Parker meets and Otto Octavius
from a different universe you know after
they kind of face-off against her or you
know kind of distract and defeated by
tarantula then it's a little hard for
Peter to grasp because from his
perspective he looked at superior
spider-man and says you're who Octavius
could have been he could have been a
good guy now this that's the thing PS
for spider-man does not know the whole
story behind superior spider-man and so
that's why he kind of looks at them and
sees them as what the guy could have
been and it's cool because what it does
is it sets things up for betrayal but
again like there's a little bit of a
skirmish at least it seems that there's
gonna be one only for Octavius to kind
of explain what's going on say hey look
I will help you here and then we can go
forward and we can focus on you know on
what this mission is on this you know
pan-dimensional calamity now again that
was the nature of superior spider-man
and that's what we kind of have to
assume this version of superior
spider-man that we're seeing was towards
the end of the story other reason why I
say that's one of things Barry mom the
reason why I say that guys is for those
you guys who never read superior
spider-man
when Doctor Octopus first took over the
body of Peter and went forward as that
version of spider-man that what ended up
happening is he was focusing one on kind
of like improving Peter's life and then
as time went on he understood what it
meant to be a hero
so he went from this antihero to an
actual hero and then it was like okay
we'll fight the good fight I'm still
arrogant and I'm still kind of a dick
but like I'm being a good guy that's
what made him so awesome that's what I
loved about superior spider-man so much
was was how he was written how his
character was developed by Dan Slott but
in this instance because of how he's
acting here we can largely assume he's a
version of superior spider-man towards
the end of the story so of course with
the two of them face off against arrays
and defeat him quite readily I mean it's
it's a pretty handed defeat what this
does is is because the nature of Doc Ock
a superior spider-man Peter Parker goes
with him ps4 Peter Parker says okay fine
because of what you've shown me in terms
of your character who you are what
you're about to don't go with you know I
remember Miles Morales exists alongside
Peter in the in earth one zero four
eight in that ps4 universe and so of
course this is basically you know Peter
saying hey look you got a garden s down
like it's your job to make sure
everything's okay you know Mary Jane
Watson is kind of like the person behind
the scenes help me peter out while also
working for the present so it's it's
kind of a cool little scenario as it
unfolds it's very like Clark Kent and
Lois Lane like in terms of the
relationship between Peter and and Mary
Jane but you know with with him kind of
saying his goodbyes and then going with
superior spider-man they essentially
jump into the future to whatever this
master threat happens to be now what we
end up finding out here is that this is
basically the return of the inheritors
now for those of you guys who don't know
what that means I will explain this
again once we actually get into Sparty
Spyder getting proper the inheritors had
been around for a while like more lund
had been around for a while but we
didn't really know how deep the
rabbit-hole went until we got into
spider-verse and what we ended up
learning was that were more lund was
kind of like a vampire that fed on
people who symbolized animals which were
not gonna go into because there's a
little bit bonkers what we ended up
learning was that more lund was only one
of several inheritors and those
inheritors themselves would literally
like reach out into the multiverse grab
spider totems and then bring them back
in consume their life essence and so
what ended up happening was that at the
end of spider-verse the inheritors
themselves were kind of defeated by
being dropped off on what was basically
a nuclear irradiated world because it's
what affected them the most was all the
nuclear fallout and radiation because
they either was having to kind of reside
in in a safehouse what we end up
learning here is that somewhere along
the line that the various members of
what was essentially the spider
community were sending drones in to
check on the inheritors to make sure
that one they were there and to to see
whether or not they had died but what
ended up happening was the inheritors
were taking these drones and breaking
them down the drummer's were basically
sending signals through the dimensional
barriers back to those who were watching
them and then informing them of what was
going on what this did is it created a
tether it created a bridge if a signal
could be sent back from the drones to
those individuals who were watching the
inheritors than what it meant is the
inheritors could ride that signal what
it also meant was that this is
information being sent back and forth
and so using cloning technology what the
inheritors had been doing is they had
basically been transferring their
essence from
they were trapped on back into the model
universe in order to transfer their
consciousness and then create new bodies
and resurrect themselves and so that's
why this has really been popping off
because it was basically like a panic
button it was hit an SOS that was hit
the big red button was smashed and
saying the inheritors are coming back
which is kind of turned into a regather
entire spider universe so again that's
one of the reasons why in order to
really understand spider gedan you have
to read spider so I invite you guys to
check out my video our videos on dance
lots amazing spider-man run and then my
videos on superior spider-man and then
I'll actually upload a full story video
on spider-verse so you guys can get
caught up on that as well but with that
being said guys were you I'd bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys with
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
[Music]
[Music]